so I kind of just want to talk about
video games today sorry I mean I hope
you'll indulge me I am still a male
teenage nerd I mean I can't escape these
things I feel the need to talk about
this because I recently bought Super
Mario Galaxy 251 stars so far by the way
if you're interested if you've been
watching my video blogs for a while you
might remember a younger Charlie being
excited about Super Mario Galaxy 1 I
made this video back in November 2007 so
that's a 17 year old Charlie there with
a Super Mario Galaxy sticker stuck to
his head I'm not as obsessed by computer
games as I was back then um I like to
think that I've grown up probably
haven't I was actually talking to a new
friend of mine recently called Erik hi
Erik if you're watching he asked me what
I was doing this weekend and I said I
was gonna be playing a computer game
I'll point out that Erik is a grown-up
so you know completely fair of him to
maybe be a bit worried about me and he
said something that made me think a
little bit and I will reenact what he
said using his book yeah I've never
really gotten into video games I can't
really do an American accent sorry he's
never really gotten into video games
which is fine and Erik if you ever are
interested in playing some games I'm
happy to recommend some to you but him
saying that made me think about what a
lot of other people do think about video
games which is that they don't really
want to get into them because they think
they're stupid to me someone saying that
they hate computer games feels the same
as them saying that they hate films or
that they hate music I mean nobody hates
music I mean some people have music that
they hate sure but those same people
have music that they love and the same
is true I think of computer games for
example I'm not a big fan of Call of
Duty I mean I can see objectively why
it's a good game but I don't really go
in for shooting people in the head in a
war scenario I kind of prefer shooting
gun booze with star bits and running on
dinosaurs if you're watching this video
which you obviously aren't I don't know
why I said that I found that people who
watch these videos are usually you know
at least a little bit like me so you're
probably the kind of person that at
least likes video games a little bit so
in case you are someone who hates video
games or you at least know somebody who
hates them I would always say give them
a go because the world of video games is
massive there's gonna be something that
you're gonna like and you can be really
missing out because I mean I know the I
find video games can sometimes be even
more immersive than a film and that's
what I wanted to say today in kind of
defense of video games yeah man pick up
the video
massives or something sorry again for
being a bit of a nerd I mean I'm not
ashamed of Who I am but sorry that you
had to watch it and I am going to go and
collect some more stars so you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool hello